Salut, en ce moment, on est en plein dans les partiels, dans le brevet, dans le bac, dans les rattrapages pour certains
et je sais aussi que certains d'entre vous n'ont pas encore commencé les révisions.
Bon, c'est pas trop tard, et on va voir ce qu'on peut faire.
Générique !
Si je vous dis que vous avez été nombreux/nombreuses à m'envoyer des messages sur les réseaux sociaux
pour pouvoir faire des révisions de dernière minute, je serais un menteur.
Vous avez été plus que nombreux !
L'année dernière à la même période j'avais fait une vidéo un petit peu dans ce style là.
Je vous la mets par là.
Je vais essayer d'en faire une un peu plus poussée, un peu plus complémentaire, peut-être un peu plus efficace.
Et avant d'attaquer le vif du sujet, je vous donne deux informations très importantes:
le prochain live c'est demain, ce dimanche 28 mai à 18H sur la chaîne.
J'ai essayé de vous préparer des surprises.
La deuxième info c'est que vous êtes encore nombreux à me poser des questions sur le livre
et il y a une vidéo qui répond à toutes les questions sur le livre qui est sortie, et je vous la mets aussi en lien dans la description.
Donc dans les faits, l'examen est en train d'approcher, soit vous avez pas révisé, soit vous êtes en train de stresser parce que vous voulez encore réviser.
On va partir du principe que vous n'avez pas révisé, parce que qui peut le plus... peut le plus.
Avant de parler de ce qu'il faut
faire, on va parler de ce qu'il ne faut pas faire.
Il ne faut pas se noyer sous un monticule de travail.
Ca ne va rien résoudre au problème vous allez juste être débordé par une montagne de choses à apprendre.
Il y a cinq étapes pour réussir des
révisions de dernière minute quand on a rien foutu avant.
Et je sais de quoi je parle...
La première étape, c'est la stratégie.
Si vous connaissez un peu la chaîne, vous savez que je suis fan de "L'art de la guerre" de sun tzu.
Et la stratégie c'est toujours la première étape d'un plan d'action.
Donc vous allez prendre une journée complète pour poser la stratégie et le contenu.
Ca on va y revenir, au contenu. Je sais qu'une journée c'est long mais on n'est plus à un jour près, je
crois qu'on est d'accord avec ça.
Dans un premier temps vous allez lister les priorités des matières à réviser.
Et ça, les priorités, vous allez les trouver avec les coeffs.
L'idée c'est pas de faire l'impasse sur les petites matières, mais les matières où vous êtes déja bons,
les matières à très faibles coeffs, ce ne sont pas vos priorités.
La priorité c'est les gros coeffs. Vous allez donc concentrer vos efforts
sur les coeffs les plus rentables en terme de points.
Avec comme objectif secondaire
quand même d'avoir le minimum syndical dans toutes les matières.
Et oui, là le but ce n'est pas de chercher la mention non plus.
Dans votre stratégie vous allez aussi
établir un planning de révisions.
Qu'est-ce que vous allez faire des jours
suivants, supprimez tout ce qui est superflu, vraiment.
Donc vous faites un espèce d'emploi du temps
pas forcément heure par heure mais sur quoi vous allez concentrer vos efforts, jour par jour.
Ca, ça va déjà prendre un certain temps dans cette journée que vous allez concentrer à l'élaboration de votre plan stratégique.
Et dans cette même journée, vous allez faire appel à la deuxième étape à savoir le contenu.
Je ne sais pas pourquoi j'ai parlé comme ça.
Le contenu c'est essentiel c'est ce que vous allez devoir réviser. Quelle formidable découverte !
Donc vous allez récupérer, assembler,
organiser tous vos cours.
Les cours de vos potes si vous n'avez pas très bien pris vos cours.
Les fiches que vous pouvez avoir sur certains cours ou les fiches récap que l'on peut aussi retrouver sur le net.
Peut-être aussi des livres, comme les annales sur le diplôme que vous êtes en train de passer.
Vous rassemblez tout ce savoir, vous le triez par matiète, et ensuite vous le triez par sous thèmes.
Je pense que ces deux étapes vous prennent une matinée complète.
Faites une petite pause, allez manger et on va passer à ce que vous allez faire
l'après-midi de cette préparation aux révisions intensives.
L'après-midi, vous allez créer vos outils. On va concentrer ça sur trois outils principaux.
Tout d'abord, des fiches de révisions. Peut-être que dans votre contenu vous en avez déjà, les vôtres ou celles de certains potes, ou celles que vous avez trouvé sur le net.
Ensuite vous allez créer des mindmaps de vos cours.
Les mindmaps ce sont des cartes mentales, j'en ai déjà parlé dans une vidéo.
Des outils pour faire ça, c'est très simple:
Quelques feutres qui écrivent bien et qui sont agréables à utilisr c'est important.
Un surligneur, une règle, et vous structurez votre pensée sur votre mindmap.
Pour faire votre carte mentale vous allez utiliser l'imaginaire et ça c'est génial, parce que ça permet de beaucoup mieux retenir les choses.
En plus vous allez faire un travail créatif qui va venir de vous, donc ça aussi ça va consolider ce savoir.
Mais surtout pour créer le mindmap vous allez être obligé de synthétiser l'information.
Le global. Peut-être pas le détail, les dates par exemple si c'est de l'histoire ou ce genre de chose.
Mais le global vous allez être obligé de le comprendre pour pouvoir le reverser sur le mindmap.
Et ce sont toutes ces choses et tout ce processus de création des mindmaps qui vont déjà vous faire gagner un temps exceptionnel pour réviser.
Dans une vidéo de l'année passée , les abonnés, vous, vous m'avez envoyé vos propres mindmaps. Je vais vous mettre cette vidéo là en lien dans la description
comme ça vous pourrez voir des exemples et vous inspirer de cette méthode là.
Et ensuite sur la fin de journée, début de soirée, vous allez faire ce qu'on appelle des flashcards.
Là aussi j'ai fait des vidéos sur le sujet, vous pouvez la retrouver également dans la description.
Avec les flash cards vous allez pouvoir retenir des informations très concrètes: une date, une formule, ce genre de choses...
Mais vous allez aussi pouvoir mettre des petits mindmaps en flash card.
Vous allez les créer de manière recto/verso.
Je vous rappelle qu'une flash card ça se fait dans les deux sens et ça peut se réviser dans les deux sens.
Un exemple bâteau très concret:
Je pourrai très bien écrire sur une fiche bristol d'un côté "21 juin", de l'autre côté "fête de la musique".
Et si je prends la flash card du côté "fête de la musique", il faut que je me rappelle que c'est le 21 juin.
Et si au contraire je la prend du côté "21 juin", il faut que je me rappelle que c'est la fête de la musique.
Vous voyez un petit peu le principe.
Là aussi le travail de création de ces flash cards, va vous obliger à identifier quelles sont les choses très importantes dans votre stratégie à retenir.
Et le fait de les créer, ça va amorcer un processus de mémorisation.
Et là on imagine qu'on est à la fin de cette journée que vous avez consacrée à la préparation de votre révision de dernière minute,
vous avez vu la stratégie, le contenu, vous avez les outils, il ne reste plus que la méthode à appliquer, une petite annexe.
La méthode est très simple, vous allez maintenant uniquement réviser vos mindmaps, et vos flash card.
Les fiches de lecture vous n'allez pas les réviser en tant que telles, vous allez les relire de temps en temps.
C'est-à-dire que si vous avez un doute sur la compréhension de quelque chose, vous relisez les fiches de lecture que vous aviez.
On parle bien de lire, pas forcément de mémoriser.
Les flash cards comme vous avez peut-être pu le voir dans mon ancienne vidéo, ça se fait en temps normal par jour, à la semaine, au mois, tous les 6 mois, un an...
Là... on n'a pas le time, là...!
Vous allez donc fonctionner avec les flash cards par demi journées.
Si il vous reste 6 jours de révision, vous créez 12 boites avec les flash cards.
Tout est dans la première boite, la première matinée vous n'allez faire que ça, que de la flash card, que de la flash card, et partout où vous avez bon, vous mettez dans la deuxième boite pour l'après midi.
À chaque fois que vous avez bon, vous passez dans la troisième boite qui sera pour le lendemain matin, si vous avez faux vous la laissez là.
Alors là je fonctionne par demi journée, c'est un peu hardcore.
Vous pouvez aussi fonctionner par journée, c'est vous qui voyez.
Mais vous voyez le principe, vous réappliquez le principe des flash cards, sur le nombre de jours qui vous restent.
Et pour réviser le mind map, c'est très simple, vous essayez de le visualiser, vous voyez ce qu'il vous manque,
Vous le relisez, vous le regardez, vous revisualisez...
Et vous vous assurez surtout dans les mindmaps de bien comprendre l'arborescence que vous avez créée.
Et c'est presque terminé.
Maintenant il y a juste 2 choses à faire qui sont essentielles.
La première chose c'est de bien dormir.
La compréhension, la mémoire, tout passe par un cerveau en bonne forme, et pour ça il faut bien dormir.
Il faut dormir entre 7 et 8 heures, donc obligez vous à ça.
Pioncez et pioncez bien.
Et la dernière chose, et là je pense que c'est la chose qui vous fera le plus plaisir.
C'est que le fait de réviser durant des heures est une mauvaise idée reçue.
Si vous voulez faire une bonne acquisition et une bonne mémorisation, je vous conseille de réviser par tranche de 20 minutes et toutes les 20 minutes, faire une pause de 5 minutes.
Et quand je dis faire une pause de 5 minutes, c'est faire une vraie pause, faire autre chose, complètement autre chose.
Vous pouvez rallumer le téléphone, vous faites ce que vous voulez, mais qui n'a plus rien à voir avec les révisions.
Et vous faites comme ça: 20 minutes, 5 minutes, 20 minutes, 5 minutes...
C'est ce qu'il y a de plus efficace.
Après peut-être que vous aussi vous avez des techniques personnelles, je vous incite à les mettre dans les commentaires et à les partager avec tout le monde.
Vous pouvez vous répondre entre vous, ou vous donner des astuces ça ce serait top, que vous puissiez vous aider dans les révisions de dernière minute,
et nous dire quel diplôme vous êtes en train de passer, tiens, ça ferait comme un mini sondage dans la vidéo.
Et puis j'espère sincèrement que ça vous aidera et que vous viendrez nous dire si vous avez eu votre diplôme ou pas.
Partagez cette vidéo aux personnes que ça pourrait aider.
N'oubliez pas de liker et de vous abonner.
Et rendez-vous très bientôt, donc demain à 18H pour ceux qui seront là au LIVE.
Ciao !
[musique de générique de fin]